PRIYA GUPTA: Let's begin
with the obvious question.
Why should one care about
distributed training?
Training complex neural networks
with large amounts of data
can often take a long time.
In the graph here,
you can see training
the resident 50 model on
a single but powerful GPU
can take up to four days.
If you have some experience
running complex machine
learning models, this may
sound rather familiar to you.
Bringing down your training
time from days to hours
can have a significant
effect on your productivity
because you can try
out new ideas faster.
In this talk,
we're going to talk
about distributed training, that
is running training in parallel
on multiple devices such
as CPUs, GPUs, or TPUs
to bring down your
training time.
With the techniques that you--
we'll talk about in this talk,
you can bring down your
training time from weeks or days
to hours with just a few
lines of change of code
and some powerful hardware.
To achieve these goals,
we're pleased to introduce
the new distribution
strategy API.
This is an easy way to
distribute your TensorFlow
training with very little
modification to your code.
With distribution strategy
API, you no longer
need to place ops or
parameters on specific devices,
and you don't need to
restructure a model in a way
that the losses and gradients
get aggregated correctly
across the devices.
Distribution strategy takes
care of all of that for you.
So let's go with what are
the key goals of distribution
strategy.
The first one is ease of use.
We want you to make minimal
code changes in order
to distribute your training.
The second is to give great
performance out of the box.
Ideally, the user shouldn't
have to change any--
change or configure any settings
to get the most performance out
of their hardware.
And third we want
distribution strategy
to work in a variety of
different situations,
so whether you want
to scale your training
on different hardware
like GPUs or TPUs
or you want to use different
APIs like Keras or estimator
or if you want to
run distributed--
different distribution
architectures
like synchronous or
asynchronous training,
we have one distribution
strategy to be useful for you
in all these situations.
So if you're just beginning
with machine learning,
you might start your training
with a multi-core CPU
on your desktop.
TensorFlow takes care of
scaling onto a multi-core CPU
automatically.
Next, you may add a
GPU to your desktop
to scale up your training.
As long as you build your
program with the right CUDA
libraries, TensorFlow
will automatically
run your training on the GPU
and give you a nice performance
boost.
But what if you have multiple
GPUs on your machine,
and you want to use all
of them for your training?
This is where distribution
strategy comes in.
In the next section,
we're going to talk
about how you can use
distribution strategy to scale
your training to multiple GPUs.
First, we'll look at some
code to train the ResNet 50
model without any distribution.
We'll use a Keras API, which
is the recommended TensorFlow
high level API.
We begin by creating
some datasets
for training and validation
using the TF data API.
For the model,
we'll simply reuse
the ResNet 50 that's prepackaged
with Keras and TensorFlow.
Then we create an optimizer that
we'll be using in our training.
Once we have these pieces, we
can compile the model providing
the loss and optimizer and
maybe a few other things
like metrics, which I've
omitted in the slide here.
Once a model's compiled, you
can then begin your training
by calling model dot fit,
providing the training
dataset that you created
earlier, along with how many
epochs you want to
run the training for.
Fit will train your model and
update the models variables.
Then you can call evaluate
with the validation dataset
to see how well
your training did.
So given this code
to run your training
on a single machine
or a single GPU,
let's see how we can use
distribution strategy
to now run it on multiple GPUs.
It's actually very simple.
You need to make
only two changes.
First, create an instance
of something called
mirrored strategy and second
pass the strategy instance
to the compile call with
the distribute argument.
That's it.
That's all the code
changes you need
to now run this code on
multiple GPUs using distribution
strategy.
Mirror strategy is a type
of distribution strategy API
that we introduced earlier.
This API is available
intensive on point 11 release,
which will be out very shortly.
And in the bottom
of the slide, we've
linked to a complete example
of training [INAUDIBLE]
with Keras and multiple
GPUs that you can try out.
With mirror strategy,
you don't need
to make any changes to your
model code or your training
loop, so it makes
it very easy to use.
This is because we've changed
many underlying components
of TensorFlow to be
distribution aware.
So this includes the optimizer,
batch norm layers, metrics,
and summaries are all
now distribution aware.
You don't need to make any
changes to your input pipeline
as well as long as you're using
the recommended TF data APIs.
And finally saving
and checkpointing work
seamlessly as well.
So you can save with
no or one distribution
strategy and a store
with another seamlessly.
Now that you've seen
some code on how
to use mirror strategy to
scale to multiple GPUs,
let's look under the
hood a little bit
and see what mirror
strategy does.
In a nutshell, mirror strategy
implements data parallelism
architecture.
It mirrors the variables
on each device EGPU
and hence the name
mirror strategy,
and it uses AllReduce to
keep these variables in sync.
And using these
techniques, it implements
synchronous training.
So that's a lot of terminology.
Let's unpack each
of these a bit.
What is data parallelism?
Let's say you have end
workers or end devices.
In data parallelism, each
device runs the same model
and computation but for
the different subset
of the input data.
Each device computes
the loss and gradients
based on the training
samples that it sees.
And then we combine
these gradients
and update the
models parameters.
The updated model is then
used in the next round
of computation.
As I mentioned before, mirror
strategy mirrors the variables
across the different devices.
So let's say you have a
variable A your model.
It'll be replicated
as A0, A1, A2, and A3
across the four
different devices.
And together these four
variables conceptually
form a single
conceptual variable
called a mirrored variable.
These variables are kept in sync
by applying identical updates.
A class of algorithms
called AllReduce
can be used to keep
variables in sync
by applying identical
gradient updates.
AllReduce algorithms can be
used to aggregate the gradients
across the different
devices, for example,
by adding them up and making
them available on each device.
It's a fused algorithm
that can be very efficient
and reduce the overhead of
synchronization by quite a bit.
There are many
versions of algorithm--
AllReduce algorithms
available based
on the communication available
between the different devices.
One common algorithm is what
is known as ring all-reduce.
In ring all-reduce, each device
sends a chunk of its gradients
to its successor on the ring
and receives another chunk
from its predecessor.
There are a few more such
rounds of rate and exchanges,
and at the end of
these exchanges,
each device has
received a combined
copy of all the gradients.
Ring-all reduce also uses
network bandwidth optimally
because it ensures that both the
upload and download bandwidth
at each host is fully utilized.
We have a team working on
fast implementations of all
reduce for various
network topologies.
Some hardware vendors
such as the Nvidia
provide specialized
implementation
of all-reduce for their
hardware, for example,
Nvidia [INAUDIBLE].
The bottom line is that
AllReduce can be fast
when you have multiple
devices on a single machine
or a small number of machines
with strong connectivity.
Putting all these
pieces together,
mirror strategy uses
mirrored variables and all
reduce to implement
synchronous training.
So let's see how that works.
Let's say you have two
devices, device 0 and 1,
and your model has two layers,
A and B. Each layer has
a single variable.
And as you can
see, the variables
are replicated across
the two devices.
Each device received one
subset of the input data,
and it computes the forward
pass using its local copy
of the variables.
It then computes a backward
pass and computes the gradients.
Once agreements are
computed on each device,
the devices communicate
with each other
using all reduce to
aggregate the gradients.
And once the gradients
are aggregated,
each device updates its
local copy of the variables.
So in this way, the devices
are always kept in sync.
The next forward
pass doesn't begin
until each device has received
a copy of the combined gradients
and updated its variables.
All reduce can further
optimize things and bring down
your training time by
overlapping computation
of gradients at lower layers in
the network with transmission
of gradients at
the higher layers.
So in this case, you can see--
you can compute the
gradients of layer A
while you're transmitting
the gradients for layer B.
And this can further
reduce your training time.
So now that we've seen
how mirror strategy looks
under the hood, let's look
at what type of performance
and scaling you can
expect when using
mirror strategy with
multi-- for multiple GPUs.
We use a ResNet 50 model
with ImageNet dataset
for our benchmarking.
It's a very popular benchmark
for performance measurement.
And we use Nvidia Teslas
V100 GPUs on Google Cloud.
And we use a bat
size of 128 per GPU.
On the x-axis here, you
can see the number of GPUs,
and on the y-axis, you can
see images per second process
during training.
As you can see, as we
increase the number of GPUs
from one to two
to four to eight,
the images per
second processed is
close to doubling every time.
In fact, we're able to
achieve 90% to 95% scaling out
of the box.
Note that these numbers were
obtained by using the ResNet 50
model that's available in our
official model garden depot,
and currently it uses
the estimator API.
We're working on Keras
performance actively.
So far, we've talked a lot about
scaling onto multiple GPUs.
What about cloud TPUs?
TPU stands for a tensor
processing units.
These are custom ASIC,
designed and built by Google
especially for accelerating
machine learning workloads.
In the picture here, you can
see the various generations
of TPUs.
On the top left,
you can see TPUE1.
In the middle you
can see cloud TPUE2,
which is now generally
available in Google Cloud.
And on the right
side you can see
TPUE3, which was just announced
in Google I/O a few months ago
and is now available in alpha.
And in the bottom
of the slide, you
can see a TPU pod, which
is a number of cloud TPUs
that are interconnected to each
other using a custom network.
TPU pods are also now
available in alpha.
So if you want to
learn more about TPUs,
please attend Frank's talk
tomorrow on cloud TPUs.
In this talk, we're
just going to focus
on how you can use
distribution strategy to scale
your training on TPUs.
It's actually very
similar to what we just
saw with mirror strategy,
but instead we'll
use TPU strategy this time.
So first you create an instance
of a TPU cluster resolver
and give it the name of
your cloud TPU resource.
Then you pass the clusters over
to the TPU strategy constructor
along with another argument
called steps per run, which
I'll come back to in a bit.
That's it.
Once you have the
strategy instance,
you can pass it to your
compile call as before,
and your training will
now run on cloud TPUs.
So you can see, the
distribution strategy
makes it really easy to
switch between different types
of hardware.
This API will be available
in the next TensorFlow
release, which is 1.12.
And in the bottom
of the slide, we've
provided a link to
training ResNet 50
with the estimator API
using TPU strategy.
So let's talk a little bit
about what TPU strategy does.
TPU strategy implements
the same architecture
as mirror strategy.
That is it implements
data parallelism
with synchronous training.
The cores on a TPU,
there are eight cores
on a single cloud TPU.
And these cores are connected
via fast interconnects.
And this means that you can
do AllReduce really fast
to aggregate the gradients.
Coming back to those
steps per run parameter
from the previous
slide, for most models
the computation time
of a single step
is small compared to the sum
of the communication overheads.
So it makes sense to run
multiple steps at a time
to amortize these overheads.
So setting this number
to a high value like 100
will give you the best
performance out of the TPUs.
The TPU teams are working on
reducing these overhead so
that in the future you
may not need to specify
this argument anymore.
And finally you can
also use TPU strategy
to scale to cloud TPU pods,
which are, as I mentioned,
in alpha release right now.
TPU pods consist of many
clouds TPUs interconnected
via fast network.
And this means that AllReduce
across these different all TPU
pods can be really fast as well.
So that's all about cloud TPUs.
I'll hand it off to my colleague
Magnus to talk about scaling
onto multi-node with GPUs.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Thank you.
So that was how we scale
on multiple GPU cores
from the single node.
What about multiple nodes the
way we have multiple computers?
Because the fact is
that even though you
can cram in a lot of
GPU cards, for example,
on a single computer,
sooner or later, if you
do massive amounts
of training, you
will need to consider
an architecture where
you can scale out the
multiple nodes as well.
So this is an example where we
see four worker nodes with four
GPU cards in each of them.
In terms of support
for multi-GPU--
multi-node support,
we have currently
support for premade estimators
in terms of [INAUDIBLE] 1.11,
which is subject to
be released shortly.
And we are working
very, very hard
with some awesome developers
to get this support into Keras
as well.
So you should be aware
that Keras support will
be there as soon as possible.
However, if you do
want to use Keras
with a multi-node
distribution strategy,
you can actually achieve that
using a little trick that's
available in the Keras,
and that's called--
it's a function called
the estimator 2 model.
estimator 2 model--
the model 2 estimator.
TF dot Keras estimator-- model
2 estimator that takes a Keras
model as an argument
and then it actually
returns an estimator
that you can
use for multi-node training.
So how do we set up a
multi-node training environment
in the first place?
This was a really,
really difficult problem
up until the technology
that's open source now
called Kubernetes was released.
And so we-- even though you
can set up multi-node training
with TensorFlow without
running Kubernetes,
it will certainly help to use
Kubernetes as the orchestration
platform to fire
up multiple modes.
And Kubernetes this is
available in most clouds
GCP and I think AWS
and others as well.
So how does that work?
Well, a Kubernetes cluster
contains a set of nodes.
So in this particular picture,
you can see three nodes.
In each of them
is a worker node.
And what TensorFlow requires
in order for this to work
is that each of these nodes have
an environment variable called
TF underscore config defined.
So every single node that
you're having your cluster
needs to have this
variable defined.
And in this TF config, you
have two parts, first of all,
the cluster part,
which defines all
of the hosts that participates
in the distributed training,
all the nodes in your cluster.
And the second one
is really to specify
who am I. What is my
identity within this cluster?
So you can see the
task here is 0.
So this worker is host 1 port 1.
It's 1.
That's host 2 port, and
it's 2, meaning that it's
host 3 and that-- at that port.
So that's how you need to
configure your cluster in order
to do this.
So that is really cumbersome
to go around and round to all
of the nodes and actually
provide the specific
configuration and
Kubernetes provides--
so how do you configure this--
Kubernetes provides
an excellent way
of doing that through its
deployment configuration,
the yaml file, so
you can actually
distribute the configuration,
the environment variables
to set on the respective nodes.
So how do we integrate
that with TensorFlow?
Well, it's part of
the initial support.
And this is just
one way of doing it.
There are multiple
ways, but this
is one way that we've tested.
You can use a template
engine called Jinja.
And you create a file
called a Jinja file,
and there is
actually such a file
available in the
TensorFlow slash ecosystem
repository, observe not
the TensorFlow repository.
This is the ecosystem.
There will be a directory
under that repository called
distribution underscore
strategy that
contains useful functions to use
with distribution strategies.
So you can use this
file as a template
in order to
automatically generate
the deployment dot yaml
for the Kubernetes cluster.
So what would that look like
for a configuration like this
where we have three nodes?
Well, it's really,
really simple.
The only thing you need
to do in this file--
the Jinja file-- is the
highlighted configuration
up here.
You set the worker
replicas to three nodes.
The rest is just code that you
keep for all of the executions
you setup to do.
Make sense?
So this is actually a macro
that populates TF config based
on this parameter up here.
So that's very simple,
but what about the code?
We've now configured
the Kubernetes cluster
to be able to do
this distributed
training with TensorFlow,
but there are also
some stuff we need
to do with the code
as we had for the
single node as well.
So it's approximately the same
as for single node, the multi
GPU configuration.
So this is the estimator lingo.
So I provide a config here.
You see the run config?
It's just a standard
estimator construct.
And I set the train
distribute parameter to TF
dot config distribute collective
AllReduce strategy, so not
mirrored strategy for
multi-node configuration.
It's collective
AllReduce strategy.
And then I specify
the number of GPUs
I have available for each
of these workers that I
have my cluster.
And that's it.
Given that I have
that config object,
I can just put that as part
of the config parameter
when I do the conversion from
Keras over to an estimator.
And I now have multi-GPU--
multi-node, multi-GPU
in each of the nodes
configured for TensorFlow.
And so let's look at this
collective AllReduce strategy
because that's something
different than what
we talked about previously
with a mirrored strategy.
So what is that thing?
Well, it is specifically
designed for multiple worker
nodes.
And it's essentially based
on mirrored strategy,
but it adds
functionality in order
to deal with multi-host or
multi-workers in my cluster.
And the good thing about
this is that it automatically
selects the best algorithm
for doing reduce--
the AllReduce function
across this cluster.
So what does that mean?
What kind of
algorithms do we have
for doing AllReduce in a
multi-node configuration?
Well, one of them
is very simple--
very similar to what we have
for a single node, which
is to ring-all reduce
in which case the GPUs,
they just travel
across the nodes
and they perform an overall ring
reduce across multiple hosts
and GPUs.
So essentially the same
as for single node.
It's just that they
are traversing hosts
with all of the penalties
associated of course
of doing that depending
on the interconnect
between these hosts.
Another algorithm is
hierarchical all reduced.
I think that this really
complicated English word.
And what happens here
is that we essentially
pass all of the variables
up to a single GPU card
on the respective hosts.
See that.
We all send them missing
an error-- two errors over
here-- with one arrow here.
Never mind that.
They're supposed to all send
this stuff to GPU 0, GPU 1.
And then we do an AllReduce
across the nodes there.
And the GPUs performing
that operation then
propagates back to
the individual GPUs
within its own node.
So depending on network
and other characteristics
of your setup and hardware,
one of these solutions
would work very well.
And the thing with
collective overdue strategy
is they will automatically
detect the best algorithm
to use in your
distributed cluster.
So that was multi-node,
multi-accelerator cards
within the nodes.
There are also other ways
to scale to multiple nodes
with TensorFlow.
And one of them--
how many of you
are familiar with
parameter server strategy?
Parameter servers?
This is the classical way of how
you do TensorFlow distributed
training.
And eventually this--
actually this way,
the classical way, you should
not continue to do that.
You should actually--
once we roll out
distribution strategies,
that's the way to go.
So what I'm describing here
is essentially the parameter
server strategy, but
instead of describing it
in the old classical
way of doing TensorFlow,
I'm going to
describe how to do it
with distribution strategies.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
If you didn't understand that
and you haven't used TO1,
just don't worry about it.
Just listen to what
I have to say here.
To get a recap of what the
parameter service strategy is,
it's essentially a strategy
where we have shared storage.
We have a number
of worker nodes,
and they're working on
batches of shared stories.
They're working
completely independently.
Well, not completely
we'll see shortly.
But they are working
independently
calculating gradients
based on batches.
And then we have a number
of parameter servers.
So these workers, when they
are finished with the batch,
they send it up to
the parameter servers.
The parameter servers,
they have the updates
from the other workers,
so they calculate
the average of the
gradients and then pass
all of those variables
down to the workers.
So it's not synchronous.
These workers, they
will get updates
on the variables in that
synchronous fashion, which
has good sides and bad sides.
The good side is one
worker can go out,
and the other workers can
still execute as normal.
That's the way this works.
So how can we set this up in a
distributed strategy cluster?
Well, it's real easy.
Instead of just specifying
the worker replicas
in their Jinja file,
we also specify
the PS underscore replicas.
So that's the number
of parameter servers
that we have in our
Kubernetes cluster.
So that is the Kubernetes setup.
Now what about the code?
So that's also really easy.
You saw the run config--
the config parameter previously.
Instead of using the
collective AllReduce strategy--
I got that right this time--
collective AllReduce strategy,
you used the parameter
server strategy.
See that?
So it's just another type there.
You still specified the
number of GPUs per worker,
you specify the
config object to--
Keras model to
estimator function
call, and you're all done.
So very, very few
lines of code needs
changing even
though we're talking
about massively different way of
doing distributed TensorFlow--
TensorFlow training.
There is one more configuration
that we are working on.
I think we will have a release
of this in 1.11 at least
we can try out.
That is a really,
really cool setup
where you actually run
distributed training
from your laptop.
And in this particular case, you
have all of your model training
code here.
And the only thing you--
so forget about
parameter server.
Now we're back to multiple
workers and AllReduce here.
The only thing you fire
up on these workers
is the TF underscore STD
underscore server dot pi
or whatever variant
of that you want
to use because this
code is available also
in the TensorFlow
ecosystem repository.
So you can go check
it out how we did it
for this normal setup,
and you can change it
to whatever way you want.
The thing is that this
script and installation
of the workers, they don't
have the model program at all.
So when we fire up the model
training from our laptop
or workstation here, it will
distribute that model over
to those.
So if you have any changes
to your model code,
you can just make it locally,
and it will automatically
distribute that out
to all of the workers.
Now you may say, oh, that's
a hassle because now I've
got to install this
script on all the workers.
And you do not have to do that
because the only thing you do
is just specify the script
parameter in the Jinja file
that you've seen a
couple of times now--
and we have the same
number of workers here--
and that means that the
scripts will actually
start on all of these nodes.
So what we're talking about
here is the capability
to fire up a Kubernetes
cluster with an arbitrary
number of nodes.
Without any
installation of code,
you can use a local laptop,
and it will automatically
distribute the model
and the training
to all of these
worker nodes just
by having these two lines here.
What about the code?
So again, we have the
wrong config here.
And this time,
we're going to set
a parameter called
experimental distribute
to the distribute config.
And as part of
distribute config,
we are going to embed
a collective AllReduce
strategy with, as we saw
before, the number of GPUs
we have per worker.
But the distributed config
requires one more parameter,
and that is the remote cluster.
The cluster-- the
master node here
needs to know the cluster
to which it should
send all the model code
for these demos that
are waiting there for the
model code to be shared.
Make sense?
So you gotta specify
that parameters.
Then you're finishing
up your config object
in model testimony to
specify the config object.
And as you've seen
before, it's just
a couple of lines of
difference between
these different configurations.
That's really it for
TensorFlow multi-node training.
So let's summarize what we've
talked about here today.
First of all, we went through
the single node distribution
strategy setup.
We talked about the mirrored
strategy for multiple GPUs
within a single node, and we
talked about the TPU strategy
to distribute work to the TPUs.
We also went through
the AllReduce algorithm,
which is used by
distribution strategy
to be able to do this
single load distribution.
Then we talked about
multi-node distribution,
talked about using Kubernetes to
distribute TensorFlow training
using these Jinja files that
compiles or translates over
to the yaml file for deployment.
We talked about
the AllReduce using
collective AllReduce strategy.
We talked about the
parameter server setup
with distribution strategy.
And then finally we talked
about distributed training
from a standalone client
distributing the model code
over to the workers.
Work in progress.
So most of the stuff that we
talked about today, you'll
find TensorFlow dot contrib
dot distribution strategy--
you'll find that in the
TensorFlow repository.
But as part of 1.11,
many of these things
that we talked about you
will be able to start to use.
If you really want try out,
you can also check out Nike
and see how far we've gone.
But 1.11 should be out shortly.
We are working on
performance still.
This is always going
to be something
that we're going to work on
to match state of the art.
As you saw with
single node multi-GPU,
we've achieved 90%
to 95% for scaling
a performance on the GPU cards.
We're continuously
working on trying
to improve this for all of
the different configurations
we've talked about.
TPU strategy will be available
as part of 1.12 with Keras.
Right now it's only
available in estimator.
But remember we have the
estimator trick, model
to estimator within
Keras, so you can actually
take a Keras model,
convert to an estimator,
and still use GPUs strategy
that will be part of 1.11.
Multi-worker GPU support
is something we're also
working on as I said.
So that means that in Keras--
native Keras code,
we can actually
specify multi-worker
and GPU support and also
Eager execution.
How many of you are familiar
with Eager execution?
Got to check that out.
That's a really important
feature of TensorFlow.
So if you're not
using Eager, you
should definitely stop
using anything else
and start using Eager.
The entire getting started
experience of TensorFlow
is based on Eager
mode, and we will
have great performance bridges
between Eager execution
and graph mode execution and
all of this distribution.
So the entire architecture
builds on this,
so you should check it out.
Eager execution
is also something
we're working on so you can
directly in Eager execution
mode utilize multiple GPU
cards in multiple nodes
in the same way that we
discussed in the setup.
And then when we have
multi-worker GPUs,
obviously if one
fails and we talk
about this AllReduce
synchronous gradient updates,
we do have a discussion
of fault tolerance.
So that's something
we're looking into
to build into this, so we have
more resilience with respect
to defaults.
So another summary, what
did we talk about today?
We talked about the distribution
API, which is very easy to use.
It's the new way of doing
distributed TensorFlow
training.
Forget about anything
that you did before.
Start to learn about
how to do this.
We talked about
distribution strategies
having great performance
right out of the box.
We saw the scale in
between 1 and 8 GPUs
on a Kubernetes cluster.
And then we looked at how
it can scale across GPUs--
different accelerators,
GPUs as well as TPUs,
single node as well as
multi-node and TPU pod.
And that's it.
You should definitely take
a picture of this slide
because this slide summarizes
all of the resources
that we had.
And with that, we are done.
Thank you very much
for listening to this.
If you have any questions--